Ukraine's much anticipated spring
offensive hasn't yet started why not
the first obvious one is the weather
we've been waiting for the spring
weather to pass why is that important
because 60 ton tanks which will form an
incredibly important part of the punch
through Russian front lines need to be
able to operate off-road if they're
going to be remotely maneuverable and
cause Russia some problems and the
terrain in the winter and the spring is
just too soft for those very heavy tanks
also Ukraine has been given a whole mass
of new equipment tanks armored personnel
carriers missiles and weapons which it
will not be familiar with and therefore
making sure that all of their soldiers
are not only aware of how to use these
weapons but also how to maintain them
how to repair them and how to
logistically sport them is vital and
finally Ukraine has had to recruit a
whole load more soldiers to be prepared
for this spring offensive now those new
recruits are incredibly well motivated
and inspired but they're very
inexperienced and the battlefield is no
place to learn your trade so there'll be
a mass of training operational training
going on learning how to withstand the
rigors of battle so that they are fully
prepared once the offensive gets
underway
foreign
the West has naturally assumed that
Ukraine will deliver a decisive success
with the forthcoming spring offensive
president zlinski has had to work hard
with Western leaders to give them the
confidence that a David Ukraine can
actually Prevail against the Goliath of
Russia he's been very persuasive the
West has given the weapons and now
there's a huge emphasis on Ukraine to
actually deliver on the battlefield
now everybody hopes that Ukraine will be
successful with the offensive that it
breaks through Russian lines and
actually moves and takes a huge amount
of its territory back again undermining
Russian confidence potentially changing
the course of the war that is one option
however the other option is that
actually Ukraine stumbles with Russian
defenses proving incredibly stoical
Ukraine will lose three times as many
soldiers on the offense than it does on
a defense and potentially that risks
undermining Ukraine's operational
capability that would also erode the
West's confidence in continuing to
support Ukraine and would bolster
Russian confidence and therefore
potentially they could mount a counter
counter-attack and take even more land
the stakes could not be higher
there's a huge amount resting on
President zielinski's shoulders when he
decides when to start this offensive it
will be a complex plan it won't be
simple it'll have a whole mass of
deception plans associated with it it'll
have a multi-axis approach with
different lines of attack and
undoubtedly there'll be a huge Logistics
challenge with this as well
president zlinski will want that plan to
be 100 perfect the harsh reality of life
in Warfare is that 90 nearly always has
to be good enough and that will be a
challenge for zelenski to know when that
point is reached
I wouldn't underestimate the burden of
responsibility on President zlenski's
shoulders on the eve of the spring
offensive it's a huge responsibility for
one man to carry on the eve of D-Day our
prime minister Churchill dined with his
wife Clementine and applying to her that
come this time tomorrow 20
000 lives might have been lost on D-Day
on the invasion of France president
zielinski has proven to be a brilliant
wartime leader but he doesn't have the
military experience to help him make a
judgment about when to start this spring
offensive he's only been a politician
for a few years and was an actor and a
comedian before that if this was
difficult for Churchill it's an
incredibly difficult for president
zielinski to make that call given the
very future of his countries at stake
and tens of thousands of his countrymen
as well Floral Green
it's a huge burden of responsibility but
one only zelenski can carry